how's it going face-off alright latter
your duel get welcome back
I made a crazy risk with gamble
limits about to pay off what the Celtics
recover I want to self exam time I'm a
garnet point and me back what do you
know
no no I guess no well I'll tell you what
I know it's the dumbest [__] bet I
ever heard of I disagree I disagree Gary
[Music]
you taking my money all over town
placing bets I'm having very serious
second thoughts you serious right now I
know I thought that now it where's the
money right now
is it too late I'm done that means
nothing meant nothing please give me
another shot you like to win right this
is no different than that
this is my [__] way you think I'm
stupid Howard you and your whole [__]
family
aren't you free sir with your [__]
swimming pool you know that makes me
feel no who said that I told you about
how things are gonna go you like the way
things are going now
my family get the kids at it out you
having a good time yes this is me this
is how I win game now you should be
stretching huh where's your coach no
just a [__] crazy as you
you